to react to that more he gets two gold
stars one for fouchy
and one for the atf guy senator kennedy
of louisiana
that might have been the most
entertaining but yet
sad at beat down i think i've ever seen
i've been a talk show host 33 years i've
never done that good a job senator take
a bow
well i appreciate it sean it was sad
um and and look
the people that president biden has
appointed
to make policy for him
are the most radical folks i've ever
seen
and i'm not i'm not saying you know
just a reasonable disagreement
these are people that that have contempt
for
america they have contempt for americans
they think they're smarter and more
virtuous
than than the american people who didn't
vote for president biden in their
opinion
they think we're all a bunch of
deplorables we can't think for ourselves
and they think democracy
is uh is too important to be left to the
people
they ought to get to to make all the
decisions
and his his nominee to the atf
his copy of the bill of rights goes from
amendment one to amendment three
i'm convinced he doesn't believe in the
second amendment now this is america
you're going to believe what you want
but you can't ignore the constitution
when you take an oath of office
to abide by it and these are just really
radical people
and and i i just think that the bad
administration by
virtue of its appointees and otherwise
they just have this huge
blind spot about about the lives and the
problems
of middle class america
you know it is the bureau of alcohol
tobacco and
firearms i would think you'd have to
have some fundamental knowledge of
firearms
let me move on to dr flip flop fauci
uh and we were all called conspiracy
theorists
by the people that pushed the biggest
conspiracy theory ever and that is the
trump russia collusion hoax lie
but now we know that china knew early
and now we have evidence and phone
records and other
anecdotal evidence that in fact that is
where the
virus came from and china knew about it
and the the greatest evidence they knew
about it senator
is you could they had a travel ban you
couldn't leave wuhan province and go
anywhere else in china
couldn't from you couldn't travel to
wuhan from the rest of china
but you can leave wuhan and travel to
the world
is there any doubt in your mind that
china knew and hit it
and what should we do we don't know and
let me say a word about dr fauci i i
know dr fauci i respect dr fauci
i'm disappointed in dr fauci on too many
issues he has flip-flopped
like a banked catfish on too many
on on too many other issues sean you
know i'm
i'm a simple guy i like breakfast food
and
straight answers and he won't give a
straight answer he dodges bobs
weaves rope-a-dopes uh
this is this is serious business this is
not some academic frolic
of people's lives and livelihoods are at
stake now
his agency he gave money to the wuhan
lab
that was playing around with his virus
uh
he needs to tell us everything he knows
about that
what did they use the money for what
could they have used the money for
he says they did new gain of function
research gain of function just means
they they might have turned a benign
harmless virus
into a killer and he said well they
didn't use my money to do that
well how do you know um
what other labs has has he and his
agency
given money to in china or in the united
states
who else is doing this research trying
to create frankensteins
uh in terms president biden has we've
now found out he's disbanded
president trump's uh task force that was
trying to get to to the bottom
of where the the virus came from uh why
why uh dr falci says he didn't know
anything about it
now i'm not saying he did or did but he
needs to be candid
and when he find out found out why
wasn't he on the phone
to uh president biden raising fresh hell
and and i understand dr fout she doesn't
like uh
former president trump that much and and
this is america he's entitled to believe
what he wants
but that's irrelevant to me we've got to
find out
where this virus came from so we can
stop it from happening again if
and if the chinese are playing around
with viruses turning them into deadly
killers
whether especially with our money
we need to know and we need to well i
think
i think we need to they need to
compensate the world just as a start
last question i only have 30 seconds joe
biden denied any knowledge of hunter's
foreign dealings business dealings we
now know he lied senator
what should the consequences be well
president biden needs to address this
issue
president obama put him in charge of the
foreign affairs of two countries
china and ukraine and in both cases his
son walked away with
millions of dollars worth of contracts
you know the message that's sent to the
world
american foreign policy can be bought
like a sack of potatoes
and and uh president biden needs to hit
this one head on
oh it was donald trump i think i think
donald trump would be impeached over it
senator kennedy thank you as always
appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else